[Music]
thank you
and you are actually the first foreign
leader that I've had the privilege of
welcoming here as prime minister and
there's a lot of great history here in
fact this room that we're standing in
Winston Churchill made many of his
famous speeches in World War II from
this run and in the same way today your
leadership your country's bravery and
fortitude are an inspiration to us or I
look forward to us discussing what more
we can do to support you and your
country
first of all thank you very much you
supported already a lot for us you did a
lot you your government and His Majesty
the king and of course your people your
Society where we're thankful from all
our hearts from ukrainians from our
soldiers we are thankful and this
privilege to be here yes the first time
you said not the last
so we of course we'll we'll discuss very
important issues urgent support for
Ukraine and security for I think not
only for Ukraine it's about for all the
Europe so thank you thank you that you
hosting me and invited me well it's
great to have you here my friend thanks
for being here thank you everyone
thank you